I want you to remember what we've been
looking at most recently which is that
we have these ideas called teachers
right and we had this some this acidity
of a phrase treated teachers we called
them directed numbers do you remember
that I think due to the shape business
about that yesterday right uh one we
call them that why don't we call them
directed yeah fantastic it's like you
know what it's not just science it's not
just how big something is or how maybe
or something I have I could say that way
or this way and they're different to
each other we said uptown we said
left-right we said profit-loss what were
some of the other opposites that we had
that we looked at in like the first
couple of exercises yeah dis opposing
withdrawal that's another money where
you can say east-west north-south any
give you like okay no so far we've just
been focusing on my pain what these
things are and how they relate to one
another so do you remember exactly what
you did last lesson just yesterday what
was the skill that we focused on you're
just like what they're heading over what
do we do with integers any yeah very
good
it's we want to know about like what
order do they go in which one comes
first which was being transformed we
just want to understand each different
one but now we're gonna put them all
together so this is what your heading
should be the heading is adding and
subtracting
integers okay what does that have
anything to do with what we just did
okay
or just watch adding and subtracting
integers you can see now I'm talking
about operations now I'm not just like
hey what are these numbers can you tell
me a bit about them but what happens
when they interact together when you put
a few in a pile and as I see what they
do with each other okay so I'm gonna
look through with you
one two three four operations I can't
start really recently and then for each
one I'm going to give you an analogy
that will be based on this video the
will is pair beers that we just watched
so you can understand what's going on so
firstly it's not with a nice easy one
what we've been doing for years actually
if you and our positive number
those are just the normal the numbers
were used to before we even knew what
integers were right if you add a
positive number
Lex that you started with zero zero is
there in the middle if I add three
that's a positive number
what's the result the result is going to
be well the answer is great which is
bigger right I've increased in size
anyway okay so if you add a positive
number you increase okay now let's think
about this in the context of oh right
what happened right at the very
beginning when do the pair of people
came from there like the retirement
village or something like that to pick
up Oh what was his name who remembers
his date itself mr. Jorkins all right
they come to pick him up and then what
does he do what does he do he goes back
inside and yeah irrigate he adds he adds
all of these balloons and that's why he
goes Oh
roll credits okay so therefore my
analogy for adding a positive number
which leads to increase is if you add
balloons to something right and I think
we should we should remember it's helium
balloons only helium balloons a lighter
than the fullness they're going to go up
if you add balloons you go up that's
pretty simple and that's exactly what he
does now with your number line over
there on the right hand side if you have
another comment on us but if you don't
it's all right Otis enjoy a picture of
what's going on here what is this
operation in this analogy what does it
look like on the number line we just
said we start with like say zero okay if
I added three I start here and then I go
one two three
does that make sense of adding a
positive number and therefore I increase
I go to the right does that make sense
going to the right means I'm increase of
getting bigger so far so good
okay now if you can add positive numbers
you can do other things too positive
numbers right what's the opposite
operation of added rescue subtracting
very good so if I think about
subtracting if you subtract a positive
number and again we've been doing this
for years that obviously you're not
going to increase are you if you start
at zero and you subtracted three instead
of adding it you would end up at
negative three which is smaller than
what you started with does that make
sense so you decrease okay now I want
you to think to the second video right
the second video mr. Bagchi because it
has all this trouble getting his house
you know to lift off again why is that
why does he have so much trouble
actually getting in to lift off in your
room I can't number one he's got
furniture we'll get to the furniture in
a minute but there's something else that
our Russell does that's kind of
equivalent to this that causes him a
problem yeah Ben
yeah the blood's are gone right balloons
have been removed yeah that's right if
you remove balloons because the balloons
are the things that are buoyant and
they're keeping you up you remove
balloons that means you're going to go
down and of course he's at rest so
that's my state sport but if he was in
the air and you know blue started flying
off like it I think this storm seen
elsewhere then that's gonna cause
problems right you're gonna go down okay
yeah again let's draw another number
line here we got a lot of lines for each
of these on four we've done the first
one already if I draw a second one
make sure goes forever
I'm not going to label the rest of my
neighbors I just what the really
critical was if I this time subtract
three which direction am I going to go
in yeah thank you
I'm gonna go to the left right left and
down there cuts anonymous in this
context right so I'm going to go 1 2 3
to the left ok so you can see what the
subtraction does for us 1 2 3
I'm taking away 3 I'm subtracting 3 and
that lands me on negative 3 Nachi note
that by the way maybe you want to even
like that I'll write it with you that we
with you that we do the same symbol for
these two things right there's subtract
and that's an action word what what name
do we give to action with such a debate
we call them verbs right so subtract is
verb but this thing here which we use
the same symbol for that doesn't mean
subtract that means negative right and
negative is not about negative is add is
it in this context it's an adjective
right it's describing a number okay so
negative is an adjective here okay so
I've got two things same symbol but two
for meetings right this is something you
do to another and this is something
about the number describing the number
okay excellent
yeah here we go
interesting I want to think now again to
the second video and we see mr.
privilege and he's like hooked her
brussels flying away and he's stuck so
he has to resort to something in order
to actually go after all so what does he
do he empties the furniture now let's
think about this right he's buying
balloons he's not removing balloons he
is removing I guess we could say
furniture more generally speaking it's
anything with weight or mass right so
I'm gonna say
anyways if you're having weight then
what happens through the house we saw it
it went up right to your weight you go
up now what would that mean what would
that mean for our numbers and our
integers what's the equivalent operation
that goes with what happens in movies
someone has suggested see a parallel
here when you review something like in
fact remove is just another word for
subtract you agree with that yeah bother
you to suggest something
yeah very good
add a positive subtract a positive this
time if you subtract a negative
subtracting a negative now this is weird
right look at look at the pattern
awesome okay rather than saying you get
a positive right I want to think about
the differences between the numbers and
what's the action that results right
so I increase or I decrease this time
I'm going to increase you see yeah I'm
gonna go up yeah so you increase okay
now what does this look like on the
number line
okay we'll go back with the same number
would go back with three so this one I
want to go Harris and goes forever
what's the most important oh brother
double is zero
would you make sure do I get it going on
the double line I'm gonna go to that
right I'll type of increases yeah
so I'm gonna go one two three I'm gonna
end up on three but importantly I'm not
doing this I'm not adding a positive
number
I'm doing something else I am
subtracting a negative right so when I
go to the right I'm actually got me one
two three but the operation and the
number of different I'm subtracting a
negative number okay do you end up at
the same spot you're actually doing
something different though
I can't it's a relief for my board
because we right at the end
one last one I think you can point and
follow the time what's left what's the
only thing that I have to do now I'm
going to yeah add subtract subtract if I
add a negative add a negative
he can't what's gonna happen you guys
can see the pattern if I added weights
to the house what's it gonna do it's
gonna go down right that means I'm going
to decrease so this will be adding
weights right add weight
lastly we can draw the number line this
number line is effectively going to look
like that second one isn't it it's going
to the left but again please remember
with doing something different okay
we're actually doing negative numbers
now so I'm gonna go zero the most
important number one and the way that I
get there is low by subtraction but by
adding a negative number okay now this
is a weird idea right we've got all of
these symbols flying around and all of
the results seems to be the same right
adding and subtracting a negative I
think wasn't distracting maybe they may
enjoy the same spot okay but I really
really critically want you to understand
they're not actually the same something
different is happening underneath just
like balloon adding balloons and
removing weight I'm not the same action
like everything leading to the same
result